[Music]  Spice Girls fans are freaking out and  for a good reason  on Friday for the first time in six  years all five members of the 90s girl  group reunited in London Emma Bunton  Melanie see Melanie B and Victoria  Beckham were all photographed arriving  at Gerry Halliwell's house with their  manager Simon Fuller Beckham was the  first opposed to pick from the gathering  with the caption love my girls so many  kisses Bunton shared the same shot  writing great catch up with my spicy  girls BFFs always and Halliwell followed  suit revealing that hashtag girl power  is alive and well  [Music]  the last time the Spice Girls were all  seamed together was at the 2012 Olympics  closing ceremony in London and while we  don't know what this latest reunion  means just yet we are hoping for more  spice in 2018  [Music]  you